So here's what I'll suggest is my favorite ordering, is we're going to first
write a stub, daysInMonth, that will take a year and a month and return always
30, which certainly not correct. Then we'll modify our nextDay routine to use
that stub, and then, right away, we'll test it. At this point, we won't have
done anything that will actually change the outputs from what we were getting
before if things are correct. But we're now restructure the code in a way that
all we have to do is improve daysInMonth. And then we've got the correct answer.
The next thing we'll do is modify daysInMonth to be correct, except for leap
years. I'm putting off leap years as long as I can because I think leap years
are really annoying. But there are also a complexity that only comes up
occasionally. And we can have really close to a correct answer and know that
we've got all the structure of the code and everything in good place, putting
that off. So, I'll do that. Then I think it's a good idea to test again. So
we're going to do the testing again in step five, and it would have been
perfectly okay to do the testing using daysInMonth. I think it's easier to do it
using nextDay, since I can just keep rerunning the same tests that I did for
step three. Now, I've got to the point where I really can't put off leap years
any longer, so I'm going to do the leap years next, and I'll write a helper
procedure isLeapYear. That's step 6. And I'm going to test that separately.
That's another step that you could argue, well, I could test that using
daysInMonth or using nextDay. In this case isLeapYear, they're enough special
cases that it makes more sense to test that separately. Okay, and after I've
done that I should have a fully correct solution. I could test it separately,
but I'm pretty confident in the rest of my code at this point. I'm going to jump
right ahead to step K and run all the test cases. So this is order I'd
recommend, but there's plenty of other orders that make sense. One thing that
would certainly make sense would be to move the leap year stuff to the
beginning. If you like leap years, and don't want to put that off, easy to do
that separately first. The other thing that could happen is instead of using the
nextDay test, use the daysInMonth test. That would be perfectly reasonable as
well. So there are lots of correct answers to this question. The property that
they should all have, all the correct answers, is that you're writing small bits
of code that you can test independently as you go. You don't want to be writing
a lot of code and not being able to test it. That's one of the most important
things to learn as a developer is to think of ways to structure a code, to
organize the way you build code, so you're able to do meaningful tests as you go
and see the code incrementally get closer to the solution that you need for
that. As you get more confident as a programmer, you might skip some of these
steps. But part of my motivation in asking this question is, when I tried to
solve this problem myself, I had a bug in my solution, because I didn't do these
steps carefully enough. And I've tried running all the test cases and they all
failed. And, debugging it took a lot longer than if I'd followed this pattern.
What I'm going to encourage you to do as you develop your solution, is to write
code to run all these tests as part of your solution. And, what I hope will
happen, if you do these steps, testing as you go. When you finally get to step
K, and run it on all the test cases, it will magically all work correctly the
first time. Except, it won't be magic. It'll be the result of building things in
a systematic and careful way.